good morning um it's absolutely
fantastic to be here with you um this
morning at our first local energy
showcase
um and we're absolutely delighted to
have an incredible array of businesses
and community groups who share the same
passion for eco-friendly energy
by attending today's event
you've already demonstrated
your commitment to your local
environment and the part that green
energy can play
the local energy showcase is part of our
recognition of a climate emergency and
our commitment to the suffolk wide aim
to become carbon neutral by 2030.
i guess we all try and make small
changes to help combat climate change
by recycling using less plastic or
making fewer car journeys
and today we will be able to find out um
more about some of the solutions
available to support our local areas
many of you will be aware that a recent
report from the un
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has stated that the range of
published evidence indicates that the
net damage costs of climate change are
likely to be significant and to increase
over time
we can start by adapting the energy we
use so that future generations may
continue living a long sustainable and
eco-friendly lifestyle
we'll all be very very aware that um
over the last week the government has
been talking about phasing out gas
boilers in favor of air source heat
pumps in addition to rebalancing energy
prices to ensure they are no more
expensive to run
with the government's net zero strategy
in place there are big plans ahead
including a 90 billion pound investment
as well as of course securing 440 000
jobs
we will hopefully see the end of fossil
fuels
and a surge in supporting the
electrification of uk vehicles
acting now to combat climate change has
never been more important
and in a few weeks our world leaders
will gather in glasgow for cop26 and
agree how to reduce the global impact of
emissions on the environment
but on a local level there are so many
ways in which we can change the way we
use energy
with the technology we have today
let's be smart
let's be proactive and let's make
progress
today we will have an engaging panel
session on net zero in practice
alongside the terrific marketplace
stalls which hopefully you've already
had a chance to begin to look at
as well as much more that um
you know you and i can can gather as
much information as we can
so with the help of forward thinkers of
suffolk and east anglia
we today are able to um continue the
journey of educating ourselves
passing on knowledge and make real-time
changes that not only save money but
also help our local environment
and just before i conclude and pass over
to councillor jessica fleming who is the
cabinet member for environment at mid
suffolk i just want to say a special
thank you and to all our contributors
today both um at the marketplace um and
in the um platform and workshop um
contributions we really do and
appreciate all the time you've invested
in preparing for today and giving of
your time thank you
well thank you again for coming today
it's lovely to see everyone
here in person
and we know that our towns and villages
are full of people who are passionate
about their local community
and the environment and delighted that
you have taken the time
to come here and exchange ideas
on a local level there is an awful lot
of scope for community and parish
engagement in the climate change work
i understand that the government is
working
with off gem to make it easier for small
scale generators to access the
electricity market and
supply locally either through the
electricity bill which is being
sponsored by
local suffolk mp
peter alders or through other mechanisms
which are being looked at
carbon emissions have been reduced by
about 44 percent from 1990 levels
and much of that
is due to the phase out of coal and
industrial offshoring
further reductions in this country
involve a very different approach and
large-scale public buy-in to be
successful
the role of communities and small
businesses
that is your role
in making green power affordable
accessible and perhaps most important
desirable
cannot be underestimated
today there will be a panel session on
net zero in practice
along with
our market stall holders we have keynote
speeches coming up by philip coventry
from community energy england john
taylor from greater south east energy
hamish watson from polysolar and peter
dao from elmswell
wesley hall thank you all so much for
coming
there will also be two student
presentations and a question and answer
session held by university of suffolk
and east coast college
as well as the workshops
i would like to sincerely thank all of
our sponsors
and these include forgive me if i've
left anyone off the university of
suffolk
eastern new energy
the norse group
zenergy polysolar cronus technology
and of course babur and mid-suffolk's
building control
not only for their commitment to
addressing the issue of climate change
but also for making today's event
possible
thank you very much and
please enjoy today's session
[Applause]
you